hey ihr da draußen und willkommen zu
einem Projekt bzw zu einem Turnier was
ich jetzt genau seit 3 Wochen am Planen
bin mit einem Freund und zwar ist es das
Turnier youtubees
Minecrafter ich sag mal einfach so ein
Satz den ich mir hier schon
aufgeschrieben habe der lautet ganz
einfach ihr wollt ein together mit
concrafter einer Adventure Map eurer
Wahl machen dann macht mit bei Youtubes
next Minecraft da also das ist einfach
so ein bisschen der Slogan sage ich mal
ihr habt schon gehört was ihr dabei
gewinnen könnt und zwar könnt ihr ein
Adventure Map together mit mir machen in
ein Adventure Map eurer Wahl die ihr mir
dann vorher senden könnt blablabla diese
komplette Aktion heißt Youtubes next
Minecrafter was das genau bedeutet also
es heißt halt Youtubes nächster
Minecrafter was das genau bedeutet werde
ich nachher noch erklären und wie es
abläuft auch also es wird ein etwas
längeres Video ihr fragt euch jetzt
bestimmt wie das ganze hier ablaufen
wird deswegen fange ich mal direkt an
also es wird verschiedene Kategorien
geben die da lauten Redstone
Meisterwerke Lieder noteblock Kreationen
noteblock Kreationen und epische
Gebäudeaufnahmen oder halt allgemein
irgendwie Baukunst oder so
und außerdem könnt ihr mir jetzt auch
noch einfach Kategorien unten in die
Kommentare schreiben
die ich da in der Beschreibung einfach
noch ändern werde also die Liste der
Kategorien in der Beschreibung wird sich
noch verändern das heißt es werden es
wird nicht bei den vier Kategorien
bleiben die ich vorgeschlagen habe
sondern es werden vielleicht auch noch
ein paar dazu kommen also ihr könnt dann
einfach Videos zu eurem Thema was ihr
halt den anderen bevorzugt also Thema
ist jetzt so eine Kategorie wie z.B liad
oder Redstone könnt ihr dann einfach
aufnehmen und mir per Mail an
concrafter@googlemil.com senden in dem
betrefft der Mail sollte dann einfach
irgendwie stehen youtubees next
minecraftter Kategorie Redstone oder
Kategorie epische Gebäude oder Kategorie
Lieder oder irgendwie
sowas außerdem kann das auch ein Video
sein was ihr schon mal hochgeladen habt
allerdings muss es halt von eurem Kanal
sein aber dazu komme ich gleich noch m
da ihr ja nun wisst wie der Betreff ist
kommen wir nun mal kurz zum Aufbau und
zwar sollte darin einfach nur euer
Youtube Account stehen mehr nicht also
halt der Account V Maer des Videos und
das Video sollte als Anlage angehängt
sein das ist schon ganz gut weil ich
möchte dann nicht Youtube Links
geschickt bekommen und dann gesagt
möchten kriegen also ich möchte halt
nicht gesagt bekommen von wegen ja du
kannst dir das ja selber runterladen
guck hier das ist von mir und das Beste
wäre dann wenn der YouTube User dann
irgendwie 50.000 Abonnenten hat und da
schreibt mir irgendwie so ein Kind von
dem der YouTube-Kanal ganz anders lautet
oder so also einfach euer Video was ihr
so als teilnahmebericht sage ich mal
oder als Teilnahmeformular habt oder
ausgewählt habt könnt ihr euch ja von
mir aus auch downloaden wenn ihr das
nicht mehr auf dem PC habt ähm und dann
mir einfach senden und
dann am besten sagen dass ihr wirklich
auch die ganzen Rechte daran habt denn
dazu komme ich jetzt ihr müsst nämlich
die kompletten Rechte an Ton und Bild in
dem Video besitzen das heißt keine Musik
verwenden an der ihr nicht die Lizenzen
habt wenn ihr Musik sucht welche einfach
so verwenden dürft in euren Videos dann
findet ihr in der Beschreibung zwei
Links und zwar einmal zu einer
Internetseite namens incompetech dort
könnt ihr euch ganz normal Lieder die
vielleicht gut für den Hintergrund sind
runterladen und einen YouTube-Kanal
namens papafiot Music und zwar verstehe
ich mich ganz gut und der stellt mir die
Lieder zur Verfügung die ich in mein
Let's Play verwende den habe ich auch
bei mir in der Box drin also die könnt
ihr auch einfach mal vorbeischauen oder
einfach unten in die Beschreibung
schauen die dürf ihr halt einfach so
verwenden die Musik so nun fragt ihr
euch wie wird das Ganze denn überhaupt
ablaufen oder was ist das denn alles
überhaupt also wie schon gesagt das ist
ein Turnier wo Leute mit Videos
gegeneinander antreten können und ich
werde dann nachher in Verbindung mit
euch den besten auswählen der dit mir
etwas machen darf also ich warte dann
nun von heute also heute ist halt der
20.06.2012 von heute warte ich bis 10
Tage später bis zum
30.06.2012 auf Videos die ihr mir dann
an meine e-mail was ich halt vorhin auch
schon gesagt habe wie also die E-Mail
steht auch noch mal in der Beschreibung
ich warte halt vom 20.06 von heute bis
zum 30.06 auf die Videos die ihr mir
dann an die E-Mail gesendet habt und
danach werde ich keine Videos mehr
annehmen das heißt ihr habt genau 10
Tage Zeit um euch etwas auszudenken oder
etwas bereits von euch hochgeladenen per
E-Mail zu senden und wie gesagt den
Aufbau der Mail findet ihr auch noch mal
unten in der Beschreibung und derreff
und so kennt ihr ja mittlerweile alles
so jedenfalls danach werde ich dann in
diesem
30.6 wo halt schlusstermin ist quasi
werde ich mir genau um 24 Uhr die Mails
Filtern einfach einfach abspeichern die
Mails werde mir die dann durchgucken und
werde mir in jeder Kategorie die Ich
dann zu dem Zeitpunkt in der
Beschreibung aktualisiert habe wenn das
dann z.B irgendwie sechs Kategorien sind
mit Redstone und notebox und alles werde
ich mir zu jeder Kategorie jeweils vier
Leute raussuchen die ich von denen z.B
werden bei der Kategorie Redstone 20
Leute
insgesamt ein Video gesendet haben werde
ich mir von denen dann vier Leute
aussuchen die ich da ganz cool finde die
ich dann einfach so bewertet habe die
genaue Bewertung werdet ihr nicht
erfahren einfach ich sende dann einfach
die vier besten Videos davon
quasi wähle ich aus weil es kann ja z.B
nicht sein dass ich alle Videos von
denen einfach hochlade wenn er dann
einfach so ein Video ist wo einer durch
eine Redstone Schaltung eine Fackel
anzündet und dann vielleicht noch ein
TNT Block anfängt zu brennen das kann ja
nicht sein dieser hier ich dann einfach
aus und wähl halt dann sofort vom Anfang
Hal nur die besten vier raus
so ähm
blablabla blablabla und ach so genau
diese vier Videos in jeder Kategorie
werde ich dann immer an einem Tag auf
meinem Kanal also hier auf concrafter
hochlade und lasse euch dann anhand von
Daumen hoch und Daumen runter abstimmen
wen ihr von den vier Auserwählten der
jeden der jeweiligen Kategorie am besten
findet der titelaufbau der Videos wird
dann z.B in der Kategorie Kategorie
Redstone so aussehen der wird dann
einfach sein ynm also youtubees next
Minecraft abgekürzt J y nm Redstone
Doppel Video 1 Doppel automatischer
Toaster von Minecraft LP n ein Beispiel
oder vielleicht ein Video y nm noteblock
Video 3 Schwarz und Weiß Lied von
Schland Fanboy 1999 oder irgendwie so na
ja dann habt ihr nach diesem Upload
datatum der jeweiligen Kategorie zwei
Tage Zeit um abzustimmen wer danach die
beste Bewertung hat kommt damit dann
automatisch ins Finale und dann komme
ich auch noch mal ganz kurz zu einem
Ausnahmefall und zwar wenn zwei Personen
die gleiche Bewertung haben und somit
auf Platz 1 Punkte gleich wären dann
gewinnt derjenige mit mehr Daumen hoch
und wenn diese dann gleich sind dann
gewinnt der mit weniger Daumen runter
aber allerdings kann das ja nicht sein
und wenn das dann halt auch noch mal
gleich ist dann denke ich mir einfach
spontan irgendwas aus dass ihr dann noch
mal bei Facebook abstimmen könnt wenn
ihr dann irgendwie besser findet oder so
Facebook Link ist auch ganz oben in der
Beschreibung von daher na ja
die Punkte habe ich gerade erwähnt und
zwar wird 1% ein Punkt sein das heißt
wenn z.B jemand 100 positive Bewertungen
hat und eine negative hat er infolge
dessen so ungefähr 99% Daumen hoch das
heißt 99 Punkte in dem Fall wenn ander
dann 99% also auch 99 Punkte hat dann
tritt halt die regelnkraft dass ich die
Daumen hoch Vergleiche und Daumen runter
und danach dann halt bei Facebook so die
Tage dann nach diesem
30.6.12 2012 wo dann die Videos alle
fertig sein sollten die könnten dann
quasi so aussehen das ist wieder nur ein
Beispiel z.B an dem 2.7 ist 1 2 3 4 5 6
das ist zwei Tage genau ich habe gerade
geguckt ob der juni 31 oder 30 Tage hat
mit meinen Fingerknöcheln na ja egal das
ist auf jeden Fall zwei Tage nach diesem
Abgabetermin sage ich mal lade ich dann
z.B blablaa an einem Tag zur gleichen
Zeit alle vier Videos zur Kategorie
noteblock hoch damit alle und dann z.B
zwei Tage später also vom 27 sind die
dann hochgeladen dann am 4.7 kommt dann
ein Video mit dem Finalisten der
Kategorie noteblock weil dann habt ihr
genau 48 Stunden Zeit um für jeden eine
Bewertung abzugeben für je das ist
natürlich blöd wenn ihr jedem Daumen
hoch gibt oder jeden Daumen runter das
ist genauso als wenn ihr gar nicht
abstimmt also am besten einem Daumen
hoch oder irgendwie einen Daumen runter
und dem anderen dann Daumen hoch oder so
einfach irgendwie so abstimmen na ja
jedenfalls am 27 wie schon gesagt kommen
dann alle vier Videos zur Kategorie
notblock z.B und am 47 Z Tage später
kommt dann Video mit dem Finalisten dann
am 5.7 kommen dann wieder alle vier
Videos zur Kategorie Redstone z.B und
dann am 7.7 wieder zwei Tage später der
Finalist das heißt immer z. ein Tag die
vier Videos und dann zwei Tage später
habt ihr fertig abgestimmt dann kommt
der Finalist dann wieder ein Tag später
kommen wieder vier Finalisten in der
anderen Kategorie und davon dann wieder
zwei Tage später das andere aber das
müsst ihr eigentlich nicht verstehen
denn da werdet ihr drüber informiert
einfach im in der abobox ich habe das
scha verstanden wenn ihr es nicht
verstanden habt ist nicht schlimm
einfach in der abobox gucken und dann
werdet ihr das schon sehen na ja nachdem
ich dann alle Videos von den Finalisten
auch hochgeladen habe werde ich dann
noch mal ein Video machen wo ich diese
noch einmal vorlese und dann werde ich
jeden einzelnen kontaktieren per Youtube
PN und per E-Mail und diese müssen dann
ein komplett neues Video bis zum
Finaltag drehen dieser Finaltag wird
dann genau eine Woche nach dem Video wo
ich alle noch mal nenne stattfinden das
heißt wenn ich alle nenne z.B am
ähm z.B kann ja ungefähr sein dass das
am 14 Juli sein wird wenn ich da alle
nenne muss eine Woche danach also am 21
Juli von jedem das Finale Video
abgegeben werden so jedenfalls kommen
wir dann mal zum Finaltag wie schon
gesagt wird das Finale 1 ach Finale 1
das das Finale wird ein Tag nach dem
Video mit den Finalisten stattfinden
also in nach dem Video wo ich die ganzen
Finalisten nenne an diesem Finaltag
werde ich dann alle Videos von den
Finalisten zur gleichen Zeit bei Youtube
freischalten also die die mir halt
zugesendet wurden und die Bewertungen
von eurer Seite aus abwarten dieses
abwarten wird dann diesmal drei Tage
dauern und dann konform mir zu jedem der
Finalisten ein individuelles Video ind
dem ich noch mal pro und Kontrapunkte
zusammenfasse also Kamerabewegung
Lichtverhältnisse Grafik Ton Musik
Gesamtbild und so weiter das heißt jetzt
nicht dass es eine komplette Analyse
oder ähnliches sein wird sondern nur ein
paar zusammengefasste Informationen
Effekte Stilmittel die benutzt wurden
und halt von mir in einen kurzen Video
zu jedem Finalisten mit seinem
Finalisten Video meinerseits noch mal
verpackt werden außerdem werden die
Videos von mir zu jedem Finalisten nicht
alle an einem Tag hochgeladen sondern
verteilt über eine Woche wenn ich es in
diesem Zeitraum dann schaffe vielleicht
alle zwei Tage so ein Video zu einem
finalistenv sollte eigentlich möglich
danach habt ihr allerdings nicht mehr
die Möglichkeit die Finalisten weiter zu
bewerten denn da werden eure Bewertungen
also ihr könnt die natürlich noch weiter
bewerten aber die werden halt nicht mehr
gezählt ich möchte euch nämlich nicht in
meiner ich möchte euch nämlich nicht in
eurer Entscheidung beeinflussen das
heißt wenn ich z.B sage ja der hat das
richtig gut gemacht Kamerabewegung etc
und ihr fandet den vorher schlecht
möchte ich nicht dass ihr dann sagt ja
weil Luca den toll findet finde ich den
jetzt auch toll den ge ich ein Daumen
hoch also sowas möchte ich halt nicht
ihr dürft davorher abstimmen dann mache
ich ein Video und dann sind wir fertig
aber genauso dass ich mich nicht von
euch da influssen na
ja dann habe ich nun also die
Bewertungen von euch zu jedem Finalisten
und meine Bewertung in Prozent das heißt
1% sind ein Punkt also ein P und dann
wird ein paar Tage nach meinen Videos zu
jedem einzelnen Finalisten noch mal ein
Video gemacht mit den ganzen Punkten wo
die ganzen Punkte dann zusammengezählt
werden für jede Person im
Finale das klingt für euch jetzt erstmal
relativ kompliziert allerdings ist es
gar nicht so kompliziert nur weil ihr
das gerade hier in 11 Minuten und 3
Sekunden alles so erklärt bekommen hab
kommt euch das wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen viel vor der komplette ablauft
ist natürlich schon wenig ein wenig
komplex und das wird für mich wirklich
eine Menge Arbeit sein allerdings finde
ich dass ich einfach sowas versuchen
wollte ob das gut bei Euch
ankommt weil das auch einerseits etwas
ist wo ich auch richtig Videomaterial
habe was ich hochladen kann wo ich
richtig so ein neues Projekt habe was
noch es noch weltweit noch nicht gab
glaube
ich und andererseits ist das auch gut um
meinen Kontakt mit euch so ein bisschen
zu verknü knüpfen weil ich dadurch in
Kontakt z.B mit den ganzen Videomachern
komme mit den Finalisten dann und auch
mit dem Gewinner dann auch eine
Adventure Map machen werde um Halt zu
euch ein bisschen mehr Kontakt zu haben
also ist halt von beiden Seiten aus gut
so dann habe ich mir noch so ein paar
Zusatzinformationen aufgeschrieben
also man kann dann quasi das komplette
Turnier auf jeden Fall sehen dass es ein
Monat genau oder bisschen länger sogar
als ein Monat gehen könnte in diesem
Monat werdet ihr dann aber auch eine
Menge Videomaterial bekommen also da ist
es schon nicht ohne da habt erstmal eine
Menge zu gucken ähm das einzige was ihr
nun eigentlich erstmal machen müsst ist
mir dann einfach eine E-Mail mit den
bereits genannten Informationen und dem
Video senden aber da steht auch noch mal
in der Beschreibung des Videos also wenn
ihr da mit machen wollt einfach ein
Video senden mit eurem Video und kurz
eurem YouTube-Kanal und dann hat sich
das so
außerdem würde ich mich wie schon gesagt
freuen wenn ihr mir Kategorien Ideen in
die Kommentare schreibt damit die
Kandidaten mehr Freiraum haben und diese
werde ich dann auch in der Beschreibung
aktualisieren und ja dann erstmal viel
Spaß beim Aufnehmen der Videos an die
Kandidaten und auch den Zuschauer die da
jetzt nicht bei machen da mitmachen
wollen viel Spaß beim Verfolgen das wird
auf jeden Fall ganz interessant und
auchch ja die Let's Plays gehen nach dem
Turnier normal weiter vielleicht werde
ich zwischendurch mal irgendwann
schaffen eine Folge rauszuhauen weiß ich
aber nicht jedenfalls gehen die nach dem
Turnier noch mal weiter also so ungefähr
in einem Monat so ich habe jetzt erstmal
eine Menge Arbeit vor mir
ihr könnt euch jetzt zurücklehen oder
euch sofort ran Maen an dem Video und
mir das bis in 10 Tagen zum 30.06
einfach zukommen lassen und danach
werdet ihr dann über alle genau die
genaueren information noch mal erwähnt
vielleicht kommt auch zwischendurch noch
mal das ein oder andere infovide wo ich
sage wie es dann genau weitergeht damit
die Leute dann auch wissen wie es dann
halt weitergt und ich hoffe erstmal wenn
euch die Idee gefallen hat würde ich
mich auf jeden Fall über einen Daumen
Hoch freuen oder irgendeinen Statement
sage ich mal in den Kommentaren oder
eure Meinung dazu ob ihr sowas toll
findet und dann würde ich sagen sehen
wir uns dann in 10 Tagen bei dem bei den
Videos von der ersten Kategorie und ja
vielleißig Videos machen oder halt nicht
und mir senden Ciao Haut da rein das war
Luca und ich bin hier jetzt raus von wem
ist das wohl na ja
ciao